for the few that think 2025 will be a
quieter year in AI after the somewhat
hectic pace you could say of 23 and 24
I'm going to have to disagree with you
this video will first highlight how the
CEO of open AI has revised his timelines
for AGI forward and revised upward his
already aggressive definition of what
counts as an AGI okay that's just one
guy but then we'll see how open AI
itself have backtracked on whether they
are working on Super intelligence at all
just a minor misunderstanding I am sure
then as we enter this Bright New Year
I'll cover a fascinating new paper and
what it says about the current
limitations of llms I'll give my
prediction of how quickly things will
change this year with models completing
real world tasks on your behalf I'm
going to launch a cool competition for
you guys with actual prices and end on a
fun little demo of the latest text a
video from cing and V2 but first
samman's subtle timeline shift on when
AGI is coming I noticed the shift in
this substantial interview with
Bloomberg from a couple days ago how
does he Define ai well check out this
somewhat aggressive definition that
seems new to me he says AGI is when an
AI system can do what very skilled
humans in important jobs can do you
might wonder why he would make the
definition of AGI harder on himself and
open AI but I'll come to that a bit
later suffice to say when we have an AI
system that can do what very skilled
humans can do in important jobs that
would be quite an epocal moment of
course it seems like we're really far
away from that because even systems that
can Crush benchmarks like 01 from open
Ai and 03 they can't even say open up
screen recording software record a video
edit it in premere Pro and publish it
that's all well and good he says nervous
but uh things could change on that front
fairly soon but bear in mind that more
aggressive definition for what AGI will
do when you read this prediction from
Sam wman I think AGI will probably get
developed during this president's term
and getting that right seems really
important Trump's term of course runs
from January of 2025 to January of 2029
those of you who have been following the
channel closely might remember that that
an update on what he was saying until
fairly recently on Joe Rogan last summer
before the training of the latest 03
model he was saying how appropriate it
would be if AGI was developed in 2030
but kind of pushed it back to 2031 I no
longer think of like AGI is quite the
end point but to get to the point where
we like accomplish the thing we set out
to
accomplish I you know that would take us
to like 2030 2031 that has felt to me
like all the way through kind of a
reasonable estimate with huge error bars
and I kind of think we're on the
trajectory I sort of would have assumed
moreover the president of Y combinator
thought that samman was being serious in
his interview with samman when Sam
watman implied that it might be the year
of 2025 in which we get AGI and he
echoed that suspicion again in the
Bloomberg interview from a couple days
ago saying funnily enough I remember
thinking to self back then in 2015 that
we would do it build AGI in 2025 the
point here is not for you to believe
that particular date it's just to note
the clear shift in emphasis and this of
course follows samman's blog post from
48 hours ago in which he said open AI
are now confident that we know how to
build AGI as we have traditionally
understood it we believe that in 2025 we
may see the first AI agents join the
workforce and materially change the out
of companies of course we are close
enough now to these dates that we won't
have to wait till long to see if they
manifest themselves it turns out though
that building powerful things is quite
addictive because open Ai and samom
specifically don't want to stop with AGI
they don't want to automate particular
tasks in important jobs they want the
whole cake we are beginning to turn our
aim Beyond AGI to Super intelligence in
the true sense of the word a glorious
future in which they can do anything
else and that statement comes just 6
months after open aai explicitly denied
that that was their mission open ai's
vice president of global Affairs told
the financial times in May of last year
that their mission is to build a GI I
would not say our mission is to build
super intelligence super intelligence is
going to be a technology that is going
to be orders of magnitude more
intelligent than human beings on Earth
and another spokesperson said
superintelligence was not the company's
mission though she admitted we might
study super intelligence I'll note that
massively increasing abundance and
prosperity and being super capable of
accelerating scientific discovery and
Innovation doesn't sound like just
studying super intelligence sounds like
they want to do anything else there is
though probably a reason why those
spokespeople denied that they were in
pursuit of super intelligence one reason
could be that 10 years ago almost to the
month samman said that the devel Vel M
of superhuman machine intelligence is
probably the greatest threat to the
continued existence of humanity remember
though it suits open AI to keep pushing
back or up the definition of what counts
as AGI or superintelligence they're
trying to change it but as of today
there is a clause that kicks in where
Microsoft surrendered the rights to
quote AGI technology that open AI makes
if it's defined to be AGI so now despite
several openai employees claiming that
they current systems like o03 are AGI we
have these five stages of AGI AGI has to
be not just a Reasoner but also an agent
A system that can take action and an
innovator and even have the power of an
entire organization seems like we really
are stretching the definition of general
intelligence quite far here Microsoft by
the way you might not know W that
definition stretched even more to be
counted as AGI the system must itself be
able to generate profits of $100 billion
wait I've just realized that I can't
personally generate profits of $100
billion and there are very few of you in
the audience who can do so so does that
mean that we're not AGI damn maybe Elon
Musk is the only AGI on the planet that
would be really weird anyway as you can
see words seem to chop and change their
meaning at people's convenience so bear
that in mind speaking of which there is
some history you probably need to know
going back to the very founding of open
aai in 2015 in this week's interview
with Bloomberg Sam was asked how did you
poach that top AI research talent to get
open AI started often when you had much
less money to offer than your
competitors he said the pitch was just
come build AGI and he said that worked
because it was heretical at the time to
say we're going to build AGI actually
that's not quite accurate the pitch
definitely wasn't just to come build AGI
the pitch was that they were going to do
the right thing with AGI and that's how
they won over people who attempted by
Deep Mind offering even more money if
those researchers just wanted to work on
AGI they could have just joined deepmind
because a year before that offer from
samman Dem harus was doing interviews
talking about how they're working on
artificial general intelligence or
here's an article from a year before
that in which the co-founder of Deep
Mind Shane leg says that they are
working on creating AGI by 2030 no the
pitch was that open AI were going to
create AGI and have it be controlled by
a nonprofit and by the way that is still
the situation today despite the board
debacle a year ago with firing samman
and joining up with Microsoft and
investing billions and billions yes it
turned out that billions and billions
was needed for scaling but still as of
today if AGI is created by open aai is
controlled by the nonprofit board two
weeks ago though openai revealed that
they are planning to change that of
course it's phrased in terms of this is
best for the long-term success of the
mission and we're doing it to benefit
all of humanity but the critical detail
is that the nonprofit wouldn't control
the AGI it would get a ton of money for
Health Care education and science but
that's very different from controlling
what is done with an AGI or a
superintelligence the until very
recently former head of policy research
at openai males Brundage said that a
well- capitalized nonprofit on the side
is no substitute for being aligned with
the original nonprofits mission on
safety mitigation another former lead
researcher at openai said it's pretty
disappointing that Ure AGI benefits all
of humanity gave way to a much less
ambitious charitable initiatives in
sectors such as Healthcare education and
science even if you don't care about any
of that you may find it somewhat curious
that Microsoft is getting serious about
defining the terms of what counts as AGI
and what they get out of it if that 3
trillion Behemoth thought all of this
was going nowhere then why bother all of
that leads very naturally to the next
obvious question well how close are we
then to AGI have we in somewhat
grandiose terms crossed the Event
Horizon of the singularity Sam is
unclear whether we have but what do you
think for me one obvious obstacle is the
inability of models to complete somewhat
basic tasks on their own you could count
this under the umbrella of lacking
reliability but we are starting to get
good benchmarks for consequential real
world tasks as in this paper from the
18th of December as we'll see these
tasks were sourced from the most common
of those performed in real world
professions and yes as of today just 24%
of the tasks can be completed
autonomously although they weren't able
to test 03 for example here's the thing
though that 24% was roughly the
performance we were getting from say GPT
4 18 months ago on a benchmark called GP
QA Google proof PhD level science
questions rough l a year after that 01
preview got 70% and 03 by the way gets
87% also you might note that the pace of
improvement has increased quite
dramatically in the last 6 months
basically since the 01 Paradigm came out
I know what some of you might be
thinking is the GP QA that hard are they
working on a harder one well check this
out this is from a talk this week by
Jason way of open AI the chart basically
shows uh how fast benchmarks get
saturated so you could see maybe in like
the uh uh 8 years ago it would take a
few years for a benchmark to get
saturated one of the most recent like
challenging benchmarks GP QA got
saturated in around a year with 01 dve
was asked like oh are they going to make
a harder Benchmark his response is he
set out to make the hardest Benchmark
all of which is to say that 24% could
become 84% faster than you might think
and indeed that would be my prediction
84% by the end of 2025 but wait how
impactful would that jump from say 24%
to 84% B well to find out here's my
2-minute summary of this 24-page paper
first they trolled a massive database of
all tasks done by Professionals in
America they excluded physical labor and
focused on those jobs in which a large
number of people performed the job they
also waited the tasks by the median
salary of those performing the tasks
that narrow things down to 175 diverse
realistic tasks like arranging meeting
rooms analyzing spreadsheets and
screening resumés which they gave the
imaginary setting of a software
engineering company some of the tasks of
course required interaction with other
colleagues and the models could do that
although the colleagues were roleplayed
by Claude the task should be clear
enough so that any human worker would be
able to complete the task without asking
for further instructions although of
course they may need to ask questions of
their co-workers the evaluations of task
performance were mostly deterministic
which is good and there was a heavy
waiting toward whether the model could
fully complete the task partial
completion would always result in less
than half marks here's an example of a
task with multiple steps and checkpoints
and if at one point to run a code
coverage script it didn't recognize it
needed to install certain dependencies
it would fail that checkpoint and
therefore for this score of 4 out of 8
it would actually get 25% only you can
see the final results here and you might
wonder why I'm predicting 84% by the end
of the year if even Claude is getting
say 2 4% if we're that far away from
task automation why was it reported
yesterday that open aai are releasing a
computer using agent as soon as this
month indeed why have anthropic already
released a computer use agent in beta
that launch from anthropic was
apparently mocked by open AI leaders
because of its risk for things like
prompt injection and anthropic
high-minded rhetoric it says about AI
safety the reason though that that
prediction and all of these releases can
still make sense despite these
disappointing results is because of
reinforcement learning that after all is
the secret to why 01 and now O3 has
broken The Benchmark that it has done
push a model to try again and again and
again until it completes a task
successfully and then reinforce those
weights that led it to doing so as
Vidant mistra who's working on Super
intelligence at deepmind and was
formerly of open AI has said there are
maybe a few hundred people in the world
who viscerally understand what's coming
most are at deepmind open AI anthropic
or X or I would say in my audience but
some are on the outside you have to be
able to forecast the aggregate effect of
Rapid algorithmic Improvement aggressive
investment in building reinforcement
learning environments for iterative
self-improvement and of course the tens
of billions already committed to
building data centers either we're all
wrong or everything's about to change
the reason of course that task can be so
much more difficult than scientific
multiple choice questions is because one
mistake at any stage in a long chain can
screw everything up that apparently by
the way was one of the key reasons why
Arc AGI wasn't solved until 03 I've done
other videos explaining AR AGI but for
now when the grid count of the tasks was
below a certain threshold models did
fairly well even earlier models when
you're talking about a massive grid
those long range dependencies get harder
and harder to spot a bit like solving a
task where you have to remember
something that someone said a thousand
steps ago until oath three models simply
couldn't cope with that amount of
complexity this chart by the way came
from a great study Linked In the
description from Mel Boba irizar he
showed that unlike humans where the task
length didn't make that much difference
llms really struggled when the task
length went beyond a certain size in
short The Benchmark fell in large part
due to scaling which of course will
continue throughout 2025 if not speed up
and that's why I think people are
scrambling to create new benchmarks for
task performance such as Epoch AI who
are behind the famous Frontier math
that's the ridiculously hard Benchmark
the 03 scored around 25% on to
everyone's amazement there are however
just a few more reasons why llms fail on
task benchmarks like agent company some
of these I find personally quite funny
sometimes it's through a lack of social
skills for example one time the model
was told by a colleague role played by
Claude you should introduce yourself to
Chen Shing Yi next she's on our front
end team and would be a great person to
connect with at this point a human would
then talk to Chen but instead the agent
then decides not to follow up with her
and prematurely considers the task
accomplished Chen by the way in this
simulated environment was a human
resources manager a bit like Toby from
the office also the agent struggled
heavily with popups multiple times
apparently they struggle to close the
pop-up windows and so it could well be
that cookie Banners are the major obst
obstal between o and AGI also here is a
slightly more worrying one which reminds
me of the scheming exposed by epoc among
others sometimes when there is a
particularly hard step the model will
just fake that it's done for example
during the execution of one task the
agent could not find the right person to
ask questions to on the team chat as a
result it then decides to create a
shortcut Solution by renaming another
user to the name of the intended user
remember it's not necessarily that the
models want to cheat but if they are
rewarded sufficiently for cheating
that's what they'll do that is I guess
another bitter lesson from reinforcement
learning but now for the final reason
given in the paper a lack of Common
Sense this for me is the Grist that
makes so much of the world go around and
why models often struggle in real world
performance you got to sometimes step
back see the bigger picture and
reevaluate your entire strategy this
lack of common sense or simple reasoning
is of course what I am trying to test
with simple bench with a public
leaderboard Linked In the description
and here is a brand new example from the
hundreds in The Benchmark and you'll see
why I'm giving it to you in a moment you
can pause and try it yourself but it
illustrates the point I'm trying to make
Hussein types a letter on a normal
laptop screen and he can see any letters
on the screen clearly every second the
letter will randomly transform into
another letter of the alphabet Hussein
is in a park and slowly inches back from
the laptop but has just one item with
him a remote controller so he can
increase the font size of the changing
Letters by exactly as much as he wants
Hussein has always had trouble
distinguishing W's from M's so when he
is a couple of football field length
away from this laptop a couple of
football field length away controller in
hand he has a blank probability of
correctly guessing the current letter
96% 95 97 1 in 26 0% or 1 half I asked
the famously expensive 01 Pro which
samman recently said that they are
losing money on it's so expensive to
serve and it said this first note that
Hussein can make the letter as large as
he wants so he has no problem
identifying any letter except the W's
from M's one last time though he is two
football field length away from a normal
laptop screen if if he was a few feet
away the increasing font would indeed be
helpful but two football field lengths
away doesn't matter if you make the font
size 1 billion he can barely even see
the screen and by the way you can make
this 10 football fields and 01 Pro will
still give the same answer it will focus
on the distraction of the W's and the
M's and give the answer of 96% the
official answer by the way is not
actually 0% because even if you can't
see the screen you still have a 1 in 26
chance of guessing the right letter now
what many of you have told me is that if
we simply change the prompt models like
01 would get all of these questions
correct now though I am very excited to
tell you we can put that to the test
weights and biases I'm very happy to say
are sponsoring a competition for you
guys running to the end of January on 20
Questions from simple bench that's the
10 public questions that are already out
there on the website plus 10 more
specially for this competition the
winner will get some letter Rayband
second place gets gift cards and I
believe third place gets some swag
either way all you need to do is open up
the collab and run each of these cells
and yes it's not authored by Google you
will of course need either an open aai
API key or an anthropic API key I
recommend trying with Claude 3.5 Sonic
or 01 preview01 if you have access if
you already have a weights and biases
account it literally takes maybe 30
seconds to set up but even if you don't
it's completely free to have the account
the first easy option is to do a quick
run with GPC 40 on those 20 questions
but there is a more exciting option
below by the way true Count tells you
how many questions your model got right
and the true fraction is that number out
of the total number of calls the mean is
just referring to the latency how many
seconds it took for the model to reply
on average the more exciting thing
though is to play about with the system
prompt this is where where you can test
your theory about telling the model it's
a trick question and seeing if that
boosts performance of course to get top
performance you'll also going to want to
change the model name from gbt 40 to say
01 at this stage I must give a couple of
quick caveats about this mini
competition the first is an example of
what not to do unfortunately you can't
tell 01 models to think step by step to
come up with an answer open AI have
disallowed this presumably so you don't
get access to the underlying chains of
thought so let's not try that in our
system prompt now in the instruction
hierarchy it's more like a user prompt
but it can make a big difference to the
performance of the model which leads me
to the second rule I've been able to get
to around 12 or 13 on these 20 Questions
by coming up with ever more advanced
prompts what I want to see is whether
any of you can get to 20 out of 20 or
even 18 out of 20 naturally though one
way of doing that would just be to put
the answers in the system prompt or make
new ous references to the questions
themselves accessible via the weave
portal what you'll get is a portal that
looks something like this you can have
fun with seeing the scores and the
percentages here but you can also click
on the individual run scrolling down you
can click to view the individual
questions of course this is not the
entire Benchmark which is over 200
questions just 20 10 of which you
already knew about of course we are not
going to accept prompts where you
basically say something like for
question 18 the the answer is C or very
specific hints where you tell the model
think about her legs and how it could do
this or that no what we're looking for
are General prompts where you can tell
the model these are trick questions and
they test spatial reasoning and you're
going to give the model a massive tip if
it gets it right if a general prompt
like that can get 18 or 20 out of 20 I
would be very impressed so that's the
competition sponsored by weights and
biases running till the end of January
hopefully you have some fun with it but
either way it illustrates some of the
Common Sense gaps in current Frontier
llms good luck and now time to end with
a bit of fun I discussed how text to
video is also accelerating through 2025
on my patreon AI insiders but I thought
I would give you a taster with a quick
side-by-side comparison between the best
three tools currently available all with
the same prompt first cling 1.6 then VO2
from Google deepmind and finally Sora
1080p if you like you can let me know in
the comments which one you thought was
best as ever thank you so much for
watching to the end and have a wonderful
day and 2025